suivant timidement l'exemple de pays
étrangers la france depuis la dernière
guerre ouverte plusieurs établissements
scolaires mixte bien qu'il soit encore
peu nombreux la présence de garçons et
de filles sur les vents d'une même
classe posent des problèmes d'éducation
nouveau en même temps qu'elle résout
parfois des difficultés psychologiques
et quels sont les avantages et les
inconvénients de cette formule ces
questions nous les avons posées aux
intéressés eux-mêmes et en premier lieu
à ceux qui ne savent rien des joies et
des peines de l'école mixte à des élèves
du lycée louis le grand
souhaiteriez vous faire vos études dans
un lycée mixte c'est à dire que
sentimentalement oui et même à raison si
regrets plutôt non je veux
particulièrement
partisans parce que il n'ya pas une
bonne ambiance dans la classe c'est un
mec et des filles et des garçons d'abord
et en général le confesseur et pour les
filles
je suis en spéciale serait alors normal
de travail assez impatient que je ne
pense pas pouvoir faire le même travail
dans un registre mx j'ai été habitué à
suivre des études dans un lycée qui
n'étaient pas mixtes et je crois que la
présente de jeune fille attribuerait à
un nouvel élément qui serait
mais face aux études ne peut y avoir une
certaine distraction mais enfin si
l'habitude est prise dès la 6e je crois
que ça serait parfait
ça donnerait plus de courage aux garçons
toujours évidemment se faire valoir
à nos achats peut tenir ça peut troubler
les études ça peut troubler certaines
études mais c'est comme tout faire
attention
on peut y avoir des rapports de
camaraderie qui sont très utiles quand
il y a des filles dans un lycée dans une
classe
c'est un flux sur le caractère des
garçons et réciproquement
ça améliore oui ça améliore c'est à dire
que ça réduit les différences en
veut dire que les gars on s'efforce
d'être un peu moins brute un peu moi
enfin un peu plus plus doux et les
filles aussi essaye d'être un peu plus
tôt un peu plus dégourdis quelques
innocents d'habitude quand elles sont
entre elles ainsi messieurs les garçons
se méfie mais entrevoit quand même les
bienfaits d'une éducation qui leur
permettrait de ne plus regarder les
filles comme des bêtes curieuses
pourtant croyez vous on doute encore des
vertus intellectuelles de ces
demoiselles
justement ces demoiselles et que nous
répondent tel par la bouche des élèves
du lycée du temps durs je me trouve très
bien dans un lit cette fille mais en
fait je pense que dans un lycée mixte
d'un côté les garçons travaillent de
l'autre côté les filles ça va être
peut-être à travailler mieux je conçois
tout à fait qu'on puisse faire de
l'étude dans les lycées milk seulement
je veux défendre le lieu est cette fille
parce que on a toujours on dit toujours
que les filles ont un esprit tout à fait
différent de celui des garçons en mal et
moi je trouve que malgré tout ce qu'on
peut dire l'esprit qui règne dans l'île
cette fille est très beau et donc on
peut quand même concevoir les 17 filles
aussi sont bien le trouve qu'on est
mieux dans un lycée de filles pourquoi
les techniques ne sont pas assez sérieux
son passé sérieux je trouve que entre
garçons et filles son hip hop us
ça dépend pourquoi ça dépend parce que
il ya des résultats quelquefois sont
déplorables je préférerais faire mes
études dans un lycée misc dans un lycée
de filles pourquoi ce que serait
beaucoup plus agréable comme esprit
l'iae travaillerait plus ce que les gars
on n'aime pas être dépassé par les
filles les filles n'aiment pas être
dépassé par les garçons alors il ya un
esprit de compétition partir des classes
terminales parce que ça peut créer une
très bonne ambiance de glace bien
meilleur que continuant que des filles
très très travailleuse qui ne pense qu'à
ça d'abord peut-être alors prévoir que
les filles travaillent quelque fois plus
que les garçons ce qui ne seront
peut-être pas toujours compter quand on
aura des classes mixtes on se rend
compte que souvent les filles sont plus
travailleuses savoir faire quelquefois
d'hier parlez-moi peu de l'esprit dans
un lycée de filles aux deux hélices et
fils très renfermé salaire d'un couvent
les filles sont toujours en train de
bagarre et on est tout le temps en train
de se faire des chicanes que les
professeurs sont sont houleux taille des
filles sont quand même les chants thônex
y avait des garçons ce serait je pense
que ce serait quand même plus agréable
il semble donc entre filles on s'ennuie
alors ils s'ennuient ton mois au lycée
rodin qui est mixte de la sixième à la
classe de philosophie
mademoiselle quel âge avez-vous tizi
ouzou et vous êtes en 6e 4 vous êtes
dans une classe mixte
oui est ce que ça vous plaît d'étudier
avec des garçons oh oui ça nous change
de l'école norman enquête la ctu son 4e
et ça te plaît d'être dans un lycée me
sens oui parce que les filtres avec les
garçons ça pousse les gars ont travaillé
et alors quelle différence y at il si
beaucoup plus animée c'est à dire qu'est
ce que ça veut dire pour vous animez ya
eu de plus oui est ce qu'il ya une
rivalité dans votre classe entre les
filles et les garçons
non non france demandent des choses vous
ne voulez pas absolument être classé
avant les filles aussi mais ça ça me
fait rien si je suis placé dernière les
filles du monde j'ai une bonne nati
principal quelles sont vos relations
avec vos camarades filles assez bonne
anse pas de quoi parlez vous donne tout
comme je parlerai avec des garçons et de
quoi parles-tu avec elle demain on me
demande si on a réussi un problème ou
pas y avoir quoi tu allais même
conversation qu'avec tes camarades
garçons
oui comment vous entendez vous avec les
garçons est ce que vous vous disputez et
quelquefois dif 1 et pourquoi vous
disputez vous au on se bouscule à l'iran
il ya si longtemps que vous êtes dans un
lycée mix en depuis la 6e a quitté le
lycée mixte mais lycée j'ai changer de
lycée quand même il ya une très nette
différence oui dans quel lycée thibaut
avant lycée claude monet est là enfin il
n'y avait aucune proportion gardée les
garçons étaient un amant nombre très
inférieur c'est à dire disons l'année où
j'ai quitté le lycée on était cinquante
garçons pour 3000 fille
on verra comment ça se passait dans ce
lycée bien on l'y avait pour ainsi dire
presque aucun contact entre garçons et
filles
c'était très difficile dès qu'un gars
ont essayé de parler une fille pour
quelques raisons que ce soit soit les
filles soi même les garçons se moquer
enfin trouvé sa visite papale
et maintenant on annonce s est nettement
différent joies du moins dans notre
classe c'est très équilibré
le nombre des dégâts le prêt étudiant
son fils est à peu près la même chose
est vraiment l'ambiance est beaucoup
plus sympathique veut pas tellement
différent ce jeune garçon par une fille
c'est absolument aucune différence
est ce que vous faites une différence
entre vos camarades vie et vos camarades
y en a trop lu ment pas quand on joue
pas avec elle par exemple aux autres
garçons notamment quand on discute on
discute avec elle comme avec les garçons
sur le plan scolaire et ils se tirent
une rivalité entre les jeunes filles et
les jeunes gens ah oui bien sûr
généralement les garçons sont plus forts
en mathématiques et les filles en
français et ça oblige à
ça oblige certaines compétitions c'est à
dire que les filles sont orgueilleuse et
elf à l'arrivée avant les garçons et est
ce qu'elle arrive réellement avant les
garçons oui assez souvent il faut
admettre que les filles sont plus
travailleuses et sur des choses précises
elles arrivent beaucoup mieux les gars
ont un certain amour propre défi
d'ailleurs d'être une fille première
peut-être matière ce soit bien sûr le
tapin ce moteur non fayyad même une
réalité ça peut stimuler un peu à qui
avez-vous les mêmes sujets de
conversation avec vos camarades garçons
et avec des camarades filles forcément
certains sur certains sujet n'intéresse
que les filles d'autre que les garçons
m'enfin on peut on essaye d'avoir une
conversation général si vous voulez le
plus souvent ce sont les mêmes et on
s'arrange pour ce soit les mêmes selon
vous quels sont les tic les défauts les
manies de vos camarades garçons et leurs
qualités aussi fait être un peu brusque
fasse son égard sont leurs qualités
la franchise aux fins le même effort de
d'adaptation que les films et tard à
communiquer avec les garçons sont assez
franche et ça vous mettre à l'aise si
c'est la première fois et je ne crois
que
et quelles sont leurs défauts alors le
défaut ils sont ils sont plus minime que
les jeux pour les qualités et les
défauts elles sont pas trop bavarde
non ça va nous défendre les garçons sont
plus bavards que les filles est ce que
le fait d'être dans une classe mixte
facilite vos relations amicales avec les
garçons certainement
ces temps on se rend compte en étendant
au lycée mixte qu'il est possible de
vivre vraiment en bonne camaraderie avec
des garçons sans qui aucune histoire
quels sont les rapports amicaux vous
avez avec les garçons tout à fait
amicaux sortez vous avec des jeunes gens
en dehors des cours avec des jeunes gens
du lycée oui par exemple des rendez vous
à la piscine ou au cinéma
certainement ça dépend des filles sayan
ah oui vous mademoiselle quelques fois
vous ne gagnez pas le fleuve petit on se
bouscule plus tard on temps de se parler
pourtant ces images prises à la fin
d'une récréation nous prouve que garçons
et filles n'ont pas épuisé les joints de
se retrouver séparément à l'école
alsacienne mixte depuis cent ans la
discipline veut que garçons et filles
soit avant tout des élèves êtes vous
dans une école mixte par goût personnel
ou par hasard au par hasard parce que
mon père a choisi c'était comme
mademoiselle vous êtes dans une école
mixte depuis combien de temps
dix ans à peu près et que pensez vous
justement de cette école mixte
je pense que c'est une très très bonne
chose sur précis beaucoup pour le sens
de la camaraderie qu'on peut acquérir
vis-à-vis des garçons entre filles et
garçons ça fait ça pour dire
certainement beaucoup de complexes et
aux filles et aux garçons est il selon
vous quelle différence y at-il entre
l'école mixte une école non mixtes je
préfère une école mixte parce que
keffieh
coup difficilement un collage ya
uniquement des garçons la vie n'est pas
la même que quand on est mélangé entre
filles et garçons
justement quelles différences de
billettes il sait on est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus rude entre nous
en fait moins attention notre langage
quand il ya une fille dans une école non
mixtes les garçons et les filles ne se
rend compte que dans le en dehors et ne
se rencontrent jamais à l'école alors
ils ne peuvent pas se parler souvent et
ne peuvent pas se connaître
et tandis que quand on est avec des
filles on les connaît mieux on sait la
réaction aussi ce qu'elles vont dire
c'est ce qu'elles vont faire et soi que
c'est beaucoup plus agréable que de ne
pas se voir
est ce que votre sens de la compétition
scolaire est modifiée par le fait que
vous êtes dans une place mixte
non pas du tout vous ne voulez pas
essayer de n'essayez pas de dominer les
garçons non non ce que je vous ai dit on
est des copains jouent le même jeu il
faut le jouer jusqu'au bout
j'aime mieux être en tête de classement
qu'à ce moment là pour moi je n'en vois
pas vous ne désirez pas être classés
avant les filles à tout prix hu à tout
prix nos chats vous êtes indifférent le
tout ce que ce soit la seule dans le
premier cas dans une classe mixte
y at il une unité de placement ou non
beaucoup moins on va est très uni
évidemment toujours le même système on
est une classe on n'est pas des garçons
et des filles doit aller tout seul dans
la même direction
quels sont selon vous les qualités et
les défauts des jeunes filles qui
composent votre place
leur qualité leur sérieux dans des fours
je ne vois pas par qualité on ne les
remarque pas toujours mais leur défaut
c'est que
photo des sourires par exemple pour
avoir un devoir on se laisse toujours
prendre
j'ai trouvé je trouve plus sympathique
beaucoup moins mesquin que les filles
généralement aux familles bien j'ai voté
plus que les filles sûrement beaucoup de
timidité
c'est à gros caractères puis toutes les
manières quand tous les garçons je crois
que ça les change pas beaucoup d'autres
avec des filles quand je suis là je
regarde le professeur j'essaye d'écouter
puisque vous ne regardez jamais les
jeunes filles n'ont pas tellement
avez-vous les mêmes discussions avec les
filles et avec les gagnants
c'est le plaisir les doux avec les
filles ces petits pépins habituels les
garçons c'est plus approfondie entre
garçons
on parle de tout disque avec les filles
enfin enfin un peu plus attention
on n'a pas un appareil d'une
conversation parle de films de cinéma
avec les gars on se raconte des
histoires quel genre d'histoire et
histoires drôles simplement osé avec les
garçons ont encore plus on parle plutôt
sport il rectifié les filles plutôt au
travail ou sorties sortez vous avec des
filles ou des garçons de votre classe à
ses dépens il ya 2,2 genre de sorties ou
bien au sort avec des copains alors on
va avec l'essai de la clape sur ces îles
sont des copains pour nous bien alors on
sort avec des garçons qui sont de
l'extérieur
chose sûre pas spécialement avec des
gens de l'école sortie du court je
rentre chez moi avec des garçons avec
des garçons les camarades ne s'en soient
les filles non on les voit en classe c
to stay des garçons pourquoi ne sortez
vous parlez de défi parce qu'on assène
que d'être sont la classe et puis j'ai
pas beaucoup d'amis chez ici j'aurais
été dans des classes majorité de garçons
d'une âme au sort chauffe pour inciter
avec personne mais en fait à ce poste
avec des filles et des garçons au bâton
deux autobus sur toi et tes gars sont le
prendre la camaraderie avez-vous les
mêmes sentiments moraux camaraderie que
pour vos camarades garçons exactement
les mêmes au courant oui je pense parce
que surtout que les filles n'ont pas de
roues maquillage nos talons hauts qu'ils
font qu'elles doivent porter une blouse
et vous les considérer comme des
camarades garçons au oui surtout en
classe peuvent l'être humain vous savez
à petit mon père pareil passe confié pas
réellement un garçon caché
est ce que le fait d'être dans une tasse
mx2 vassili bost relations amicales avec
les garçons peut-être je crois on a plus
l'habitude en séance et mieux comment la
parlait pourtant les vois tous les jours
quand on en voit de temps en temps se
paie difficile durant peu plus difficile
on peut plus faux si on arrive à les
connaître on ne s'en fait des amis ça
peut être vraiment des amis plutôt
qu'autre chose et qu'est ce que ça veut
dire autre chose je paca flirt par
exemple on se fait des amis et ils
seront jamais considérés comme des
flirts parce que ce sont des copains
est-ce qu'on fait beaucoup dans une
établissement mixte
on flirte beaucoup moralement c'est à
dire 10 repas platoniquement vous voyez
on essaye et puis en dernière minute
devant les copains les copines on dit si
je vais avec une telle dans le fond
l'autre me plaît aussi
alors on se dit j'irai avec aucune mais
enfin ces classes qui s'affirme des
sages est propre à démentir les propos
de plus mal intentionné
que sont-elles vue de la chair d'un
professeur
vous êtes depuis 15 ans professeur de
lettres au lycée mist de montgeron mais
je crois auparavant vous étiez
professeur à montluçon dans un lycée de
garçons et quelle différence existe-t-il
selon vos entre ces deux sortes de
l'établissement si vous préférez ces
deux formes d'enseignement
la différence essentielle porte sur le
travail les élèves dans un lycée mixte
travaille mieux pourquoi je crois pour
la raison toute simple que les garçons
sont piqués d'émulation je suis
professeur de lettres les filles
réussissent ordinairement mieux dans
cette discipline et les garçons qui ne
veulent pas être en reste font tous
leurs efforts pour égaler leur caméra
pouvez vous nous parler du comportement
de ces jeunes gens de ces jeunes filles
qui sont posées l'air je dois dire que
longtemps un verre une uniformité du
qu'on parte du comportement c'est à dire
les petites filles perdent un peu de
leur caractère mijaurée et les garçons
abandonne un peu de leur vulgarité
est-ce que la mixité pose des problèmes
pour vos professeurs elle pose quelques
problèmes dans les places de l'est
lorsque nous étudions telles pièces
classiques en première il est évident
que nous sommes obligés à une certaine
retenue une certaine pudeur dans
l'expression nous sommes obligés de
modifier ce que nous dirions simplement
à des filles ou simplement à des garçons
on y voit un faux trouver l'expression
adéquate aux uns et aux autres
certains élèves prétendre que les
professeurs aux hommes aux femmes note
avec beaucoup moins de rigueur les
élèves
jeune fille quel est votre avis ce sont
les garçons qu'ils disent et ils le
disent surtout parce que leurs camarades
filles en lettres tout au moins
réussissent mieux alors ils en éprouvent
une petite jalousie c'est naturel
justement en tant que professeur que
pensez vous des relations entre ces
garçons et ces filles
les relations entre garçons et filles me
semble parfaitement saine c'est à dire
que nous évitons avec la mixité les
déplacements qui menait les garçons
chaque soir vers les 17 filles ils sont
constamment en contact et ils apprennent
ainsi à ces styles caractère travail
relations l'avis est favorable mais
alors qu'en pensent les parents
mesdames et messieurs vous êtes tous des
parents d'élèves elle est bourrée contre
l'enseignement mix est bien pour mais
avec les aime
je crois que c'est une excellente
formule mais avec des garanties de
discipline et surtout sur le moment de
l'adaptation
moi je suis pour avec une réserve
importante en ce qui concerne les
relations entre parents et enfants
entièrement peau quand je vois qu'ils
restent à faire pour mais peu désiré
dépendance vient d'informer d'entre eux
ne sais quel est ce nouveau
l'avantagé principal lancé mme lise je
crois que l'enseignement mixte est une
formule très bonne et une chose
nécessaire parce qu'il est indispensable
que nos jeunes apprennent à se juger à
leur juste valeur
le plus beau garçon du monde dans ce
qu'elle sèche le tableau noir perd une
bonne partie de son prestige auprès de
ces demoiselles
inversement les jeunes filles sont
quelquefois obligés de descendre de leur
piédestal
j'ai quatre filles 21 19 17 et 10 ans
elles ont toutes été jusqu'ici dans les
classes de dans des lycées de filles et
je trouve qu'il y a dans les lits cette
fille une tendance entre filles étant
toujours ensemble à exagérer les
problèmes de la féminité
ouais cependant seulement mixte j'ai
profité d'un déménagement de pigeons à
paris disons la même fille d'arabie
j'avais une fille dans un lycée de
filles exclusif vers 11h30 dans le
phoenix à paris alors selon vous managez
différence yat-il et bien je trouve que
d'abord sur le plan de travail il y a
beaucoup plus d'émulation entre garçons
et filles
hop on y travaille et puis sur le plan
des acteurs aussi j'ai remarqué que d'
équilibre nerveux chez les jeunes filles
qui se sont débarrassées des complexes
que peuvent leur donner ou que peuvent
créer la proximité de papotage de
petites mesquineries féminine
quelquefois mais pourquoi le mettez vous
pas vos filles dans un lycée mixte alors
si vous êtes partisan de ce genre parce
qu'il n'y en a pas assez
parce que ce sont des raisons de
proximité une communité qui fait qu'on
met ses finances et des lycées mais
d'ailleurs je crois que vous êtes pour
lévis et mixtes mais avec une petite
restriction oui je crois qu'il ya des
précautions à prendre en particulier sur
l'adaptation à ces classes et il serait
très mauvais de faire cette adaptation
par exemple à 13 ou 14 ans et on s'est
trop tôt ou trop tard
les enfants doivent entrer très jeune
dans une classe mixte ou alors dans les
grandes places j'ai des enfants pas en
forme et j'ai deux aînés qui ont
maintenant qu'ils n'ont que 18 mois du
de différence d'âge et j'ai constaté une
différence très grande entre deux en
particulier entre
quinze ans par exemple à ce moment la
petite fille la fille est une jeune
fille et le garçon si grand soit il le
pont depuis table n'est qu'un petit
garçon alors je pense que ça peut à ce
moment-là provoqué dans la classe
justement un déséquilibre qui n'est pas
souhaitable qu'on fiabilité et alors
qu'ils sont sur les inconvénients les
dangers auxquels on peut faire allusion
je crois qu'ils ne sont pas invités et
qui ne sont pas l'apanage des enfants
qui sont dans les cours mixtes ils ont
lieu en dehors des heures de classe et
je crois qu'on évite rien mettant des
enfants ou dans des classes de version
dans les classes de filles
ces inconvénients je pense que c'est le
rôle de lait des parents de les éviter
et que c'est par une bonne relation
entre parents et enfants par une bonne
information des enfants par les parents
que mon petit pareil elle serait votre
conclusion
son enseignement mixte et bien je serai
pour les supports le développement des
lycées uniquement à condition que le
nombre des versants défi soit vraiment
bien équilibrée et bien je crois que le
problème devrait se présenter de manière
inverse du moins la situation devrait
être l'inversé de ce qu'elle est
maintenant c'est à dire qu'il y ait une
majorité de places mixte et pour les
sujets difficiles qu'il ait tout de même
des classes de berson ou n'exerce
réservé aux filles il serait souhaitable
certainement que
il se développe si toutefois les
éducateurs je veux dire aussi bien les
maîtres que les parents font ce qu'ils
doivent faire pour faciliter aux enfants
l'abord des économistes il est
nécessaire pour que l'on tire pleinement
profit de scolarité mixte que les
parents soient parfaitement éduqué
qu'ils soient eux-mêmes des éducateurs
qui est pour cela ils consentent à faire
un effort peut même dans l'expression de
la relation avec les enfants pour qu'ils
leur expliquent tout ce qui peut arriver
tout ce qui est qu'il n'ya pas de
différence est que le fait d'être
ensemble n'est pas une course de
dissipation pour contraire là encore
dont pas de réticence
et pourtant l'accord n'est pas parfait
vous êtes contre l'inflation plutôt
contre la classe donc pour les filles
surtout pour les films surtout pour les
filles pour des raisons de travail
uniquement uniquement pour des raisons
de travail parce que je pense qu'elles
peuvent rencontrer les garçons à
l'extérieur la famille
et vous pensez que elles n'ont rien de
spécial à y gagner à lorient spéciale à
égal oui je n'ai fait que deux pas se
faire des camarades qui seront de plus
ou moins choisis par leur mère
l'indépendance il ya en son temps si je
devais choisir j'aimerais mieux à l'iss
et qui ne soit pas mixtes pour qu'elle
n'évoque pas du tout parce que je
tremble pour la morale ce serait plutôt
le contraire
je tremble qu'il n'y ait une fausse
morale qui portent atteinte
ce que j'appellerais l'éveil de la
sexualité qui doit se faire normalement
qui doit qui doit être harmonieuse et
venir en son temps et ça doit reculer
il semble l'éveil des sexualités ensuite
une opinion du personnel je ne la donne
pas pour sacro-sainte pour ou contre
l'école mixte un médecin spécialiste de
l'adolescence conclut docteur vous êtes
pour ou contre lens énorme x vous
répondre il faut je crois n'a lisez un
peu plus complètement des avantages les
inconvénients d'enseignement me
prononcer voulait d'emblée les avantages
il est bien connu maintenant la plupart
des psychologues et les médecins
neuropsychiatre que cet enseignement
mixte facilite les contacts entre
garçons et filles et peut éviter par la
suite des complications psychologique
assez importante du justement à cette
méconnaissance de notre sexe par exemple
dans des familles où n'existe que des
garçons que des filles à ce type
d'enseignement mais je peux être très
utile car il nous permet
mais une maturité affective
psychologique meilleur voire
intellectuelle des garçons et des filles
et peut éviter des difficultés
d'adaptation même conjugale ultérieure
ou pré conjugales il est certain que la
coexistence sur les bancs des lycées des
garçons défi d'un ses bonheurs leur
permet de se connaître beaucoup mieux et
est un élément très important pour leur
propre maturité personnelle sur le plan
psychologique et affectif mais il est un
conte qui est absolument incontestable
que cette mixité peut entraîner des
relations sexuelles prématurée dans
certains cas avec tous les risques que
cela comporte
je dois même insisté sur ce point j'ai
l'impression très nette et la plupart
mes confrères pensent jeu fera ainsi
c'est que la jeune fille est beaucoup
plus vulnérable de 13 à 15 ans les codes
qu'après et en ce qui concerne les
lycées en particulier sont dans les
classes de 5e 4e 3e que l'on peut voir
des incidents de ce genre
la conclusion que je pourrais vous
donner c'est que dans l'ensemble mes
arguments instruments sauf quand même
nettement plus en faveur de la mixité
que contre mais qu' il ne faut pas
répondre par oui ou par non il faut
aussi dire qu'il y a des réserves à
faire qu'il ya des aménagements à faire
des préparations à faire en particulier
à l'échelle familiale avant de réaliser
cette mixité
je dirais même au risque de faire un
certain paradoxe dans les réserves que
j'ai pu formuler
je dirais même qu'il faudrait réaliser
cette mixité bien avant le lycée ou en
tout cas au plus tard pour l'entrée en
sixième et non pas comme ça serait
encore lors de certaines créations
d'établissements tout d'un coup en 5ème
4ème et des classes qui s'ouvre mixtes
ou alors si vraiment le milieu familial
ou social risque d'être trop défavorable
et que les risques sont trop grand
reporter si vous voulez à partir de la
seconde la première cette mixité qui me
paraît moins dangereuse quand alex la
santé
[Musique]